we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p our
voicemail line is made possible by our
good friends over at linguist who want
to help you take your language learning
to the next level I've been using
linguist myself to brush up on my French
I will be speaking French in France
before you know it and I love it because
it uses artificial intelligence to
adjust to your exact skill level I hate
sitting there wasting my time repeating
stuff I already know really well when
I'm trying to learn new material so
linguist works really great for that you
can try it for free no credit card
needed at linguist dot-com slash Pakman
that's Ling Vista with a V comma slash
Pakman okay last week I received a very
lovely voicemail from a woman who from
her accent sounded like she was from the
south of the United States with a
delightful turkey burger recipe I don't
know why she called me with a turkey
burger recipe but I was sort of glad she
did because it sounded really great the
egg man doesn't like it one bit and he
says he would prefer a racist hamburger
prepared by Paula Deen over the turkey
burger that was suggested last week take
a listen to the furious Eggman is that
turkey burger sounds freakin disgusting
and I'd rather eat a hamburger cooked by
racist disgusting southern horrible
woman Paula Deen although that lady did
sound like a really sweet nice version
of Paula Deen shall oh brother
yeah she sounded extremely nice I would
not have a racist hamburger prepared by
Paula Deen I would prepare I would
prefer the turkey burger I believe the
turkey burger is healthier I believe
that the woman who called in has not
said racist things the way Paula Deen
has so I just simply disagree with the
eggman here and I prefer the non racist
turkey burger we've got a great bonus
show for you today Devin Nunez says he
will soon send eight criminal referrals
to Donald Trump's Attorney General
William Bar Motel six is going to be
paying a twelve million dollar
settlement after improperly giving
guests lists
two ice immigrations and customs
enforcement and a suspected rhino
poacher has been reportedly killed by an
elephant and then eaten by lions
according to police in a story that
basically hits all of our favorite
animals so we will we will talk about
that and more on the bonus show a quick
reminder Benjamin Dixon will be filling
in for me tomorrow I will be traveling
to a meeting of the progressive media
minds in Las Vegas it's gonna be great
to see Sam cedar maybe we will be able
to come to some kind of settlement
figure on the intellectual property
lawsuit and a lot of our other friends
Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire and
other media folks so Ben Dixon will fill
in for me tomorrow and then I will be
back hosting from Las Vegas Wednesday
Thursday and Friday we will be taking
live calls as planned for the Friday
show none of that will change and it's
going to be a really great week with
hopefully some delightful and powerful
developments coming out of independent
progressive media when we all get back
how do you get access to the bonus show
it's very easy you become a member at
WWE pakman.com or you become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
that's it for me until Wednesday unless
you remember or patron in which case
I'll speak to you on the bonus show in
just a minute or two